They're talking about disclosing
UFOs and aliens and that the military
has secret alien breeding programs with
humans and stuff. They are pushing this
stuff down your throat to make you
believe that aliens exist when it is a
demonic deception. That is what all of
this is about. It's setting the stage to
make you believe that there actually can
be visitors from other worlds, that we
live in some ever-expanding universe
that's so vast. But the Bible never says
anything about that.
We got other studies about that if you
want to look into that. I looked up a
video myself to see somebody who saw
this from a plane. This is a plane shot.
And of course, when you keep on
watching, because that's another thing.
People are saying this is all
perspective. You're on the ground and it
just Of course, it looks like it's going
out that way because of the curve of the
earth and because of perspective and all
this stuff. Well, this is from right
beside the rocket.
Right beside the rocket, the rocket is
barely higher than the plane, maybe not
even higher than the plane before it
starts leveling out.
And as you can see, it's no longer going
straight up. This rocket, if you were
honest with yourself, this rocket is not
going to the moon, it's not going to
outer space, it's literally arcing out
somewhere. And when you continue to
watch the video on you know, other live
streams, you will see that it starts to
go down. It does not go up. Stop lying
to yourselves. This is not true. Uh this
lady, she was giving her speech and it
was like she just totally froze up,
forgot what she was saying. But in
reality, I think that she is wearing a
earpiece that's telling her exactly what
to say. And suddenly, she loses signal
and she's just sitting there like
has nothing to say.
You just got to see the video. Check
this out. undisturbingly
in the universe.
Uh-oh.
So,
Get, can you hear me?
I may have not learned, I know I haven't
learned everything that this journey All
right, this particular video cut off
right there, but what she goes into is
like, I know I haven't learned
everything from this journey, but what I
have learned is that Earth is a crew.
Thank you.
That's what she said. That was her final
statement. Earth is a crew.
Thank you. Wow, like how profound. Look,
these people are actors. It's no
coincidence that the news guy said that
two out of the four are straight out of
central casting. I understand a little
bit about how faking this would go,
green screen, pretending you're in
weightlessness,
things that are floating around. I get
all that. What I don't understand is why
four astronauts would walk out for
people to take pictures of and they're
not really there. That's That's kind of
strange, but when you look at what
people are taking a picture of here,
you can see there's there's no
astronauts in the pictures.
This is the weirdest thing. I don't
understand
why this would be this way. You can see
she's beside this guy's shoulder, but
somehow, he's directly in the middle of
her frame. I don't know if this is just
like super wide lens or what's going on,
but I see no astronauts.
I got questions, guys. There's no
astronauts in this
picture.
Now, I thought maybe this was a
AI-generated thing, but it goes on for
too long. The The patches on these
people have accurate words on there.
Um
I don't think that this is AI. Now, I'm
not going to say I'm flawlessly correct.
Maybe that scene was AI because to be
honest, I looked this scene up
and it was a little bit different, a
little bit different than what I see
here. So, if you guys can prove that
this is fake, this is AI,
awesome. It'll actually answer a
question for me. But right now, I got
questions.
I still think that this guy
beats anything that NASA does. I mean,
he he does it with his phone on TikTok.
This is how easy this type of stuff can
be though, because people will look at
what they're doing on on the ISS or in
Artemis and they say, "There's no way
you can fake this stuff. You're You're
crazy. You think they're just Parabolic
flight can only go for 20 seconds and
all this stuff." This dude is not on
parabolic flight. This dude's playing
with potatoes and water balloons right
there in his front yard. Somebody
tracked the flight the flights that were
happening around where Artemis 2 landed
in the ocean and he found this
interesting
plane right here. So, he types in what
it is.
Video NASA. A NASA plane.
Could this have been the plane that
dropped the capsule into the ocean?
Look, man, I know a lot of people just
think this is
reaching, like you're you're making
stuff up. You have no proof of this
stuff. But what I'm saying is there's no
proof that any of this is real.
Nobody I don't care if I know somebody
that works at NASA or whatever.
When you work at these places, it is so
compartmentalized that one person
doesn't know what the person in the
cubicle next to him is doing.
It's not like everyone there has taken a
tour of the rocket, has met the
astronauts, are you know, right there at
the launch. It is so You got janitors,
you got people who are just reading
numbers on a screen. There's so many
departments and you are just one cog in
the whole system. It's like thinking
that a bank teller really knows how much
money is in that vaulted safe back
there. They have no idea.
They don't even know how the whole
banking system works. They're just a
bank teller. We talk about predictive
programming on this channel a lot. There
was a movie that came out called Fly Me
to the Moon and the whole movie was
about faking the moon mission. And in
the scene in the movie, there's a top
secret document that says Project
Artemis.
Now, this movie came out about a year
ago, maybe maybe longer. But I think
it's very interesting that there's a top
secret document file that's called
Project Artemis in a movie that's all
about faking going to the moon.
It just so happens Artemis 1 and Artemis
2 are the missions that went to the
moon, supposedly. Very interesting. This
is where you see they can't keep up with
what they're supposed to be doing.
They're supposed to be pretending that
there's like a 9-second delay because of
how far away they are. But when you're
in a studio somewhere on Earth,
you're not going to have that delay.
You're going to see that there are some
slip-ups when they're trying to remember
this whole delay thing. These guys are
talking amongst themselves. A lady says,
"I've adjusted the fans. Give me a
thumbs up if it feels good." And the guy
gives a thumbs up before she even
finishes her sentence.
And you'll see
Glover here, I can't remember his name,
uh put his hands on his face and like,
"Oh man." And then
And then all of a sudden, they give the
thumbs up and then he's he's like, "Oh,
hey!" Like he Like, "Hey, this is my
first time giving a thumbs up. Yeah, it
feels great." Listen to this. This is
crazy. And we have adjusted the fan
speed. We'll take a thumbs up if you're
happy with it.
Oh, but Copy thumbs
>> at his face.
They're giving thumbs up. And now he's
This guy. He commented thumbs up.
You know, this is the guy who had to
pass off the microphone when they got
asked questions about the stars. Go back
and watch the other videos. We talk
about that stuff. When they got asked by
a kid, "Can you see the stars out
there?" They It was the most awkward
scene ever. They were so fidgety, like,
"Let me Let me pass the microphone to
this guy." They needed like they needed
an expert to answer the question, "Can
you see stars in space?" Come on, man.
This is a simple answer. Every All four
of these astronauts should have known
that answer. Now, this question or this
situation where she asks for a thumbs up
and he does it immediately,
this is just damning evidence right
here. I'm going to back it up so you can
see that they are just having a regular
conversation. He's not giving a thumbs
up for any other reason except to answer
this lady.
We are 3 minutes out from an on-time
start and we have adjusted the fan
speed. We'll take a thumbs up if you're
happy with it.
Copy thumbs up.
The lady even said, "Copy thumbs up." He
even said Copy thumbs up.
Wow, it happened when they were talking
to Trump as well. And then Trump
actually addresses it. He's like, "Oh,
we got a 9-second delay or whatever."
Check this out.
Administrator Isaacman, just get a quick
com check. Make sure you guys are still
on the line and we didn't
we didn't have a handover.
I am. Yes, I am.
on the line and we didn't have a
handover.
I am. Yes. You hear how quick Trump
responded, right? We just wanted to you
know, as soon as he finishes the
sentence, "I am." Right away. Listen.
Check. Make sure you guys are still on
the line and we didn't have a handover.
I am. Yes, I am. That was not 9 seconds.
Now, listen to Trump try and I don't
know what he's doing. He's can't cover
it up because he's literally giving
himself away here.
That's funny. That's not a laugh track.
That's really This is official. This is
CBS News, but people laughed for some
reason when Trump said he's here.
You uh integrity and back over to you,
Mr. President.
I I think we might have gotten cut off.
It is a long distance It's a long way.
The reception's been great. There's a
little bit of about a 9-second delay,
but uh A little bit of a 9-second delay.
You should have used a landline like
Nixon. It would have went a lot better.
This guy, man, I love this dude. His
commentary He's talking He's not a uh
flat-earther. He's not a conspiracy
theorist.
He's just a guy that wants to see some
awesome footage. But, what he says, this
is like a punchline. Like, make a meme
out of this thing because he sums it up
perfectly. Take the camera
to the window
and shut up.
>> [laughter]
>> Take the camera to the window and shut
up. He's saying, "Look, we don't care
about what you're eating and how you eat
soup out of a bag on the Artemis. You
guys all have iPhones with amazing
cameras. Why are you not" He's like,
"Every time they take a picture, it's of
Earth this big." He's like, "There's
always a perfect place that they want to
take pictures, no matter when they go. I
want to see 24/7
You know what I want to see? I want to
see you
look out the window and say, "There's
Earth. Look at this. There's the sun.
Look, there's the moon over there. Look
at all the stars." I want to see a tour
of this place, but instead, all we get
is some low-res camera mounted onto the
outside of the thing where you're seeing
the back of the engines and some distant
either in moon or Earth.
And it's terrible quality. Like, you
guys have iPhones. You should be
recording all the stuff. You should be
like, out of your minds excited. This is
amazing. We are literally looking at the
Earth thousands of miles away. Look at
the sun up there. This is amazing. You
don't see that. And this is This is how
people are reacting because
he said like he said, he was extremely
underwhelmed with what he's been shown
on this mission. I agree. A skillet
that only heats up to like 500°
will steam when you put it underwater.
It only takes like 250°
to create steam.
But, the Artemis 2 was
reaching temperatures of like 5,000°.
When I Googled it, you guys can say I'm
wrong. I Googled it, 5,000°.
If anything, it was 2,000° when it
reached the water. It was definitely It
would definitely be at
250°
and make some steam, but no steam was to
be seen. Everybody understands when
something is on fire, flaming coming
into our atmosphere at thousands of
degrees, it's not going to cool down
that quick. This scene was very
interesting. Dave caught this, Flat
Earth Dave. Dave Weiss was watching when
they were retrieving people out of the
boat.
Now, I want you to pay attention to this
guy who's on the edge of the boat. In a
couple seconds, he's going to jump out
of the boat. I'm not sure why. He jumps
out of the boat, splashes into the
water. His head disappears into the
capsule.
Crazy.
Splash.
Now, watch.
And he disappeared. I don't know. Maybe
he went under. Maybe he's swimming under
the capsule. It just looks really
strange.
Splash.
And his head goes right through the
capsule.
I guess he maybe swimming under it. I
don't know. There are just some strange
things, you know? And with AI
being on the rise and what the
technology that we have that they give
us to play with is so good that you
can't even tell if it's real or not,
except a few little giveaways for me.
The audio always has this tinny sound to
it, but you could easily equalize the
audio. People just don't do it. And And
sometimes it looks real cinematic and
stuff. But, for the most part, AI is
getting where you It's indistinguishable
between reality.
And I can't imagine what they have, you
know?
So, this is uh an article
from PBS and it's it's showing this
picture right here and it's It's got the
NASA watermark. So, it says right here,
"In this image from video provided by
NASA, the Artemis 2 Orion capsule
right separates from the service module
above the Earth in preparation for
splashdown in the Pacific Ocean." So,
this is official NASA photo. Is this
real? Is it CGI? Because every time they
were showing us a visualization, it
actually said "visualization" in the top
corner.
Nowhere does this say visualization, but
I'm like, "What is going on with the
underside of this?" The capsule itself
looks metallic blue
and there's no writing on the white part
of this
rocket. Now, when you watch the video,
it's very interesting. Check this out.
Because there it goes. Crew module just
broke free.
Oh. Can I
What just happened there?
Did you see that? Okay, so we're seeing
a video
of
the outside. We're seeing NASA written
here. We're seeing the capsule. It
starts to glitch.
What are we seeing? There's NASA's not
written on here.
The capsule looks completely different.
What is going on here? And And they're
going to go on to talk about the capsule
and how um how heat resistant it is and
all this stuff. And at the end, they
actually show
And this This is a visualization. Notice
it says "visualization" in the corner.
It says it right here.
Does the capsule have solar panels on
it?
Did the solar panels come off when it
came back to Earth? I'm so confused
about the changing of the And I know
people are going to mock me. "Oh, you're
confused. Yeah, just cuz you don't get
it doesn't mean it's not real."
What I'm saying is the capsule came
apart from the rocket.
It has solar panels on it. But, when it
came to Earth, it didn't have solar
panels. It had
um parachutes. And look at the bottom of
this thing.
Right here is what the bottom of the
capsule looks like. They're talking
about how the bottom It's like a shell
that heats up and falls off so that the
capsule doesn't get as hot as it could.
But, that's not what we see in the
picture. Look at this thing. It looks
like a
cobblestone
thing. And then, when you look at what
we what we are shown,
I'm not seeing that.
Like, I'm not seeing that cobblestone.
What is this? Is it a hole in the
middle? It looks like metal.
I'm not seeing what we're shown the
bottom and that's definitely not it.
So, yeah, I got questions, guys.
But, this is This is what the underside
of this thing looks like.
That's the underside of the capsule.
That's not what we see. What That's what
it looks like.
It's completely different.
So, you know, some people say that NASA
stands for never a straight answer. I'm
I'm starting to believe that. Make sure
you go back and check out the other
videos we have on Artemis, uh especially
this one, Proof Artemis 2 is fake moon
mission exposed, 19 minutes long. You're
going to see a lot of cool information
in there, stuff that wasn't covered
here. And especially this one as well,
the April deception. A lot of good
comments are coming in on this.
There are just way more questions than
there are answers. Nothing about this
seems legit or real. You got astronauts
who can't even remember their lines. You
got astronauts that are answering too
quickly because the delay is not there.
You got astronauts that can't answer
questions like, "Can you see the stars
in space?"
Um the rocket arced outward into the
ocean somewhere. Ziplines that leave the
There's so many questions. I just want
to get a straight answer, guys. And my
personal view, I don't believe it. I
don't believe the moon missions. I don't
believe space travel. There's always
these things. Now that you are asking
questions, now that you are seeing that
things don't line up, go back and look
at some of the old stuff. You will see
over and over green screen glitches and
harness wires. And actually, there is a
really good video on our channel. I
would love for you guys to check it out.
The video is called Proof NASA Fake Moon
Missions ISS Space. Lots of interesting
things about space. Please go check out
this video. It's going to give you a lot
of questions to ask. I can't believe we
live in a world where people mock you
for for using critical thinking skills.
Mock you for being skeptical of our
government and and what's shown to us on
the media. This is the age we live in,
the age where the thought police are out
there and they're actually in the form
of our neighbors. So,
we love you guys. We thank you guys. We
cannot do this without you. We thank you
so much if you're already giving to this
ministry. We try to reach out to all of
you guys and tell you a personal thank
you. Some of the apps like Zelle and
Cash App won't let us do that, but I'm
you right now, thank you so much. We
cannot do this without you. We love you,
and we'll see you next time on Candid
Truth.